la situación que dibuja es sombría ambas
partes perpetraron ejecuciones torturas
desplazamientos forzados y violaciones
desde que estalló la guerra en la región
de tigre hace un año el informe conjunto
de la onu y el gobierno reconocido de
etiopía detalla los abusos desde el
inicio del conflicto hasta junio periodo
en el que los rebeldes de tigre han
luchado contra el ejército etíope y sus
aliados como los soldados de eritrea
jurin durante este período todas las
partes del conflicto de tigre han
cometido violaciones de los derechos
humanos internacionales del derecho
humanitario y de los refugiados algunas
pueden constituir crímenes de guerra y
crímenes contra la humanidad el primer
ministro etíope aceptó el informe a
pesar de algunas serias reservas pero
destacó que las conclusiones no
respaldaban las acusaciones de genocidio
sin embargo la alta comisionada de la
onu para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet dijo que era necesario
investigar más ya que los equipos se
vieron obstaculizados por la
intimidación y las restricciones de las
autoridades y el gobierno de chupi nos
ha asegurado que las instituciones
nacionales han iniciado investigaciones
y procesos y hemos sido informados de
que algunos autores ya han sido
condenados y sentenciados sin embargo
existe una preocupante falta de
transparencia en si el informe llega un
día después de que el gobierno declarara
el estado de emergencia y pidiera a los
residentes de addis abeba que se
prepararan para defender la capital ante
el avance de los rebeldes del tigre
hacia el sur un portavoz de las fuerzas
del tigre dijo que las medidas equivalía
a una carta blanca para encarcelar o
matar a los tigrillos a voluntad el
conflicto ya ha dejado a unas 400.000
personas en situación de hambruna se ha
cobrado la vida de miles más y ha
obligado a más de dos millones y medio a
huir de sus hogares